I have the pleasure of introducing you
to one of the stars of maestro a sag
nominee please join me in welcoming
Carrie
Mulligan congratulations
so much good for you right now and it
makes me so happy I want to go back to
the very very beginning of the Maestro
process for you because I know you
signed on without reading a script and
it was back in 2018 so I don't even know
if A Star is Born was available yet so
at that point what was it about uh
Bradley's pitch that gave you confidence
in his story and in him as a
director um gosh so hi everyone this is
so I got very nervous all of a sudden it
was so quiet I started with a serious
question no no no no no I mean when I
was standing there it was hi um yeah it
was 2018 I was doing a play off Broadway
in New York um a onew woman show and he
came to see me in that and then he asked
me to do this and there wasn't this
script there was um a script that Josh
singer had been working on for a while
um but yes Bradley and Josh were going
to come back to it kind of aresh and
start their story so
but he did he showed me a star as born
so it wasn't out but it was finished so
I got to go and watch it and I took my
friend Zoe Kazan because I think she's
very clever and has good taste um and I
was like it's good isn't it she was like
yes it's really good um so yeah it was
just such a I was just the whole project
was so exciting and and obviously star W
was amazing and um and the more I
learned about Felicia the more excited I
was to play her oh yes I have a lot of
questions about learning about her and
applying it to your performance here but
I I wanted to go back to the idea of you
first signing on in 2018 and then the
movie didn't go into production until I
believe it was late 2021 and you made a
bunch of movies in between so is there
any particular film or experience you
had in between that you wound up looking
back on and saying to yourself I'm so
glad that happened before
Maestro that's such a good question um
yeah so 2018 so then after that I did
promising young woman um w
thank
you um I did prising young woman and
then I did the Dig and then we went into
you know a global pandemic and
everything shut down so in that time I
think originally Myro was meant to go in
2020 obviously it didn't and then again
in 2021 so everything it pushed till
2022 is when we actually started
shooting um so there was a lot of time
in there and actually the more time we
had the better really because it meant
that every time I was in New York or La
Bradley and I would get together usually
with Josh singer who co-wrote the script
with Bradley and we'd read it out um and
then we got to do cool things like yanii
Seguin who was the musical supervisor on
the film and and helped Bradley with all
the conducting um invited us to
Philadelphia and we went and narrated
candid um for three performances with a
Philadelphia film monic so we got to do
lots of sort of um I don't know scary
bonding fun things you know um which I
think meant that by the time we actually
got to filming it Bradley and I were
very close and had done lots of work on
these characters well this kind of leans
into that a little bit can you tell us
something about your prep process that
stays the same from film to film but
then also something specific to Felicia
that was a firsttime prep element for
you here I mean lot was first time with
this one same uh there's nothing really
that's the sort of from one to the next
really I think some things are so um I
think theater I always had a lot I
always felt like when I did a player had
a lot more bandwidth to do prep I don't
know if that's because there's
designated rehearsal time and with film
there rarely is um or at least in my
experience um but with this one you know
it was clear from Bradley that he really
wanted to do like very very um intensive
kind of like a workshop just the two of
us to work on Lenny and Felicia but also
that the dialect and that that you know
the way that they spoke would be very
specific so it was lots and lots of work
with Tim monik who's an amazing dialect
coach oh this might be overly prescribed
and not the way you do it but when you
are prepping to play her what is the
very first thing you find the first
thing you nail that let you say to
yourself I am on the right track but
then I also want to know the last piece
of her you found the thing that made you
think like I have a full version of her
to bring to screen now oh
gosh she's a real person I think that
was the thing that was so I played a
couple of real people but none that had
you know her her children
are all in their 60s they were really
involved um you know and so supportive I
also went to Santiago Chile and met her
wider family um so there was just a lot
of feeling of the family being very much
on our side and helping us and wanting
to give us as much as they you know but
but that was also that felt you know
you're telling someone's whole life it's
quite a um so there was lots her voice
was really key I think and just sort of
because there were there's these amazing
tapes of her speaking that she's
interviewed by John gruin he wrote a
book called the private world of Lenard
Bernstein he interviewed Lenny and and
the family and in that she talks quite
candidly about what it is to be Lenny's
wife and some of that is in the film and
some of it isn't and um I felt like it
was such a window into her and lots of
her letters and things like that so I
think I think I had her voice on these
tapes in my head for like four years
just I would listen to it instead of a
podcast you know it was just something I
would have in my ears when I was like
you know going on the the school run or
whatever just that was my kind of
background music so I think that when I
could do her voice I felt like there was
that but I didn't I think halfway
through the shoot we were still learning
stuff that went into it that's the
beauty of film making though I love that
I also have the perfect follow-up to
what you were just explaining so when
you do so much research and you have the
opportunity to spend so much time with
people who truly knew her is there
anything in particular you learn that we
don't see or hear about directly in the
movie but you held tight to it now we
could feel it influencing your
performance well you're not going to
know it will make no difference to you
at all but I'll tell you anyway um is
that well I so I I she was a painter um
as well and got much more into painting
when she sort of moved away from acting
and she and it became something that she
really loved and she was a very good
painter and her paintings are all over
the house in Fairfield which we filmed
in which is their house in there all
over her home in Santiago Chile where
her family Liv um and so painting was
something that that she and they there
was in the script at one point a huge
section where she painted and was
frustrated with the painting and it was
a lot to do with what her Artistry
became when she decided to move away
from acting or or moved away from acting
whether that was a decision or not um
and so and I hadn't painted since I was
about 5 years old so I went and had
painting lessons for about three months
in LA and then came to Bradley and was
like I can paint now and then he was
like that's not in the film anymore um
so but anyway I'm now can sort of
vaguely paint which is fun and that's F
you know that's but but I felt like a
lot of her there was so much about her
that fascinated me that you know it was
these two artists living side by side
one of whom was an artist and the other
whom was an artist that was touched by
God that everyone heralded as the you
know a voice of his generation and icon
and what must that be like to be and
Steven Spielberg who's the producer on
this film said to Bradley early on
something I thought was so poignant but
he said Felicia made Lenny her art and I
think that was that idea of artistry and
what her artistic contribution was going
to be to the world was something that
really fascinated me and the painting
was sort of a part of that oh you feel
that so much while you're watching it
and also now I feel like you should
pursue a role when you play a painter
put those skills to use now I've done it
and I'm not very good fair enough just
for fun if you could learn a new skill
or about a different profession for a
role what would you choose and why oh I
don't know scuba diving was I'll that
I'll take that I I'll wait eagerly for
that movie next um I want to ask you
obviously about working with Bradley
you've worked with a number of
exceptional directors at this point do
you notice any share traits among the
directing grades and then can you also
tell us one of a kind about Bradley as a
director um well I've I've also been
lucky enough to work with some directors
who are also actors so Paul Doo who
didn't act in the film but he directed
me Emerald Fel as an actress who direct
a promising young woman and saltburn um
we could clap for saltburn no yeah there
we go there we go different
movie um but yeah I do think there's I
mean I've worked with brilliant
directors who don't act who equally have
an amazing un you know understanding of
how actors work but I do think there's
something kind of wonderful particularly
in a moment where you have sort of an
irrational block where you can't I I
think sometimes act as are very good at
identifying that and kind of getting you
out of it and all of those three
directors could do that um Bradley the
the experience of of working with him on
this was so interesting because he was
he did something where he made the crew
feel like a part of the company so it
was the there was no real he did sort of
everything he could to remove the
artifice from film making so when you
arrived on set it wasn't there was no no
shouting action no big there was nothing
kind of technical it was very uh the
crew was sort of part of the scene so if
there's a scene in the film where you
can't see Bradley's face um like in the
doctor's office when she receives the
diagnosis there's a there's moments
where you can't see his mouth and that
in those moments he's talking to the
dolly gr mango and he's telling mango to
get closer in with the camera so
there'll be time because he wanted to
shoot so many things in wners or often
he'll be directing the crew whilst he's
in the scene with us and I but there was
nothing kind of distracting about it in
fact it felt sort of more cohesive it
felt like part of the story in a really
interesting way so he yeah he would do
that and I just don't know how his brain
works like that's a very effective
approach right there and the the wers
served the the movie and the story so so
well how about in terms of working with
him as an actor's director because I've
heard you talk about this before and I
found it fascinating you were kind of
explaining how onset when he was acting
in a scene with you he would act but via
his performance where he would make
choices to spark different choic voes in
you and I was wondering can you give us
an example of a time when that happened
yeah so he would yeah so he would Direct
by I mean he would you know he obviously
give notes sometimes but he would also
Direct by the way that he played the
scene so if he so the the Thanksgiving
Day fight scene we did um three takes of
that scene and the first two takes were
you know a fight but not that had no
Crescendo it was just a kind of weird
bitter just both of us knew that it
didn't feel
um the right way and I can't remember if
he had the milk carton in the first two
takes but on the third take he walks in
with this Milk Carton and his sunglasses
on and he didn't take them off and it
just annoyed me so much and there was
something about the way he like bumped
into the furniture all of that stuff he
didn't do on the previous take and and
it was just so much more irritating and
then and then that take was the only
take where I stood in the window it was
the only take where I moved to WS him at
the end of the scene but what's also
amazing about that is that it in the
previous two takes I'd stayed sat in the
armchair for the entire thing cuz it
hadn't you know the fight didn't take
off in the same way but at this point in
this one I moved towards him and then
there's that pause at the end of the
fight and I thought well there's no more
words so I'll just stand here cuz I knew
he was not cutting and he often would
let things roll but I didn't know what
he was waiting for and then he responded
to a voice that I couldn't hear cuz
there was no one there so he's was
talking to the children who he then
added in later and then he allowed for
just the amount of time that it would
take for a big float thing of Snoopy to
go past the window that was added in
later on green screen and then the scene
ended and you know he did all of that
live just in that SC you know like but
there was no he didn't think like one
two three he just timed it out on his
head and I didn't know what we were
waiting for the whole time I was like
and then I you know but but that's the
level of you know I don't know how he
did it basically it's the point of that
story I I feel like something like that
could answer this question but I I've
heard you you talk about how you know
how Felicia watches Leonard and how
you've been able to watch Bradley it
could kind of mirror each other in a
sense and I I wrote this down I loved
how you said it you said there were lots
of swells of Pride you had watching him
which kind of just filled my heart so I
wanted to know can you give us a couple
of examples of you know times when you
were watching him work and filled you
with that great pride yeah all the time
I mean I just think I it was just such a
massive swing you know I remember the
first day I walked on set I wasn't
shooting I came to see um what they were
doing we were at Tanglewood and it was I
wanted to come and just see and meet
people and he was you know 80-year-old
Lenny conducting William that was the
first scene he shot in the entire film
and that's one of the last scenes in the
film and I just thought
I can't at first of all I thought
I'm going to have to like really up my
game this is but but secondly I just
thought wow it's so it's so huge what
he's attempting to do and he was
successfully doing it on day one and
that was what was so kind of a inspiring
but that went the whole way through but
the thing that really got me was so we
we shot most of the film in New York and
then we had a couple of months off and
then we shot elely cathedral which is
that six minute thing it's one of my
favorite scenes of the whole damn year
which is yeah which is incredible and
you and he was again lonard Bernstein
dialect like holding a cigarette you
know and it's the London Symphony
Orchestra who are arguably the like most
serious terrifying brilliant you know
but they're proper proper you know they
don't around and they they're
sitting there you know looking up at
this actor you know who's dressed up
like Lena Burnstein and I just thought
the nerve of him to do that like that's
so and I was nervous and I didn't have
to do anything I just had to stand there
and address but I was like I hope
they believe me like I'm just in a dress
but you
know I'm was pretending to be older than
I am and I just you know I was
intimidated by them just as an actor and
let alone doing anything musical so I
thought like that was a massive thing
and he spent all day thinking that he
hadn't got it right and I think probably
by like very very high musical standards
he hadn't got it right but to a Layman
or to basically 90% of the room it
looked amazing but he couldn't he wasn't
happy and then he ConEd this shot that's
in the film and he did it and in that
take I was genuinely just so proud of
him I watch a I watch a scene like that
and I hear him talk about it too and I
think to myself like oh he must be a
perfectionist as an artist but then I
read a quote Matthew libatique had said
this he was talking about working with
Bradley and he says when you do you have
to be open because things could change
and they always change for the better so
can you give us an example of a scene
where you all went in with a plan
something changed and offered something
new and it made a scene even
better I mean we we we did the the thing
I think we had more was that we would
just invent scenes you know so we would
so there's a scene where we're sort of
sitting by the swimming pool and and
we're sort of disagreeing about Tommy
but it's shot from very far away and you
can't really you can't see us but it's
sort of and so Bradley and I were
sitting there that day and we were
setting up to shoot something else and
we were talking about whatever we had
been doing and he said we should just
shoot this this conversation right here
let's just shoot this and he went and
set it up and I just stayed there my
iPhone was sitting like on the which is
very unprofessional I was sitting on
because I wasn't thinking we were
filming anything and I said should I
move this he said no I said should I
take my hat off he was like nah it
let's just do it and we shot that we
improvised that scene and then and then
he cut and he was like move on and I was
like that'll never be in the film um but
it was and but it was like that kind of
liveness that made it so fun cuz you
were like it was like putting a collage
together I didn't even know what was
going to be eventually in the film but
it was you know we were always just
inventing I always love talking about
the idea that that films change every
single step of the way in the script
phase on set in the edit and then again
when an audience receives it and gets to
process it their own way is there
anything about the audience reaction to
this movie that you know has either
surprised you or maybe even made you
having been in the movie rethink
something you did I don't know I just
think it's so funny how funny everyone
finds the Snoopy thing I mean
um I love that but I no I don't know
I've only watched it once with an
audience I watched it the LA premere was
the only time I've seen it that's the
only time I've seen it finished but
that's the only time I've seen it with
an audience so it was quite kind of
weird and overwhelming so easy for me to
sit here and be like you should watch
your good work over and over and then no
we went and introduced it in IMAX um and
that I didn't watch it but I was like oh
not seeing your face that big that's not
good for anyone um but I would love to
sit through and watch it with yeah but
it's an odd experience it's something
else it's something very special going
into filming of all the ambitious scenes
in this movie which one did you think
would be most challenging for you to
pull off and ultimately was that indeed
the most challenging or did a different
one Catch You by surprise I thought
everything from when she was unwell at
the end was going to be the most
challenging but it wasn't it was more it
was the scene um and the talking to
Shirley in the dino where she's telling
the story about the date that goes wrong
was the most challenging I think it was
cuz it was one of the few scenes where
Bradley wasn't Lenny and i' had gotten
so used to just acting with him and I
loved acting with Sarah Silverman she
was so brilliant but I just suddenly got
and it was also a scene that when I read
it and this often happens when I read it
I thought that's such good writing and
then I thought about it a lot and then I
thought I'm going to completely it
up on the day and I got to it and I did
I got stuck in my own head but Bradley
was just incredible um but that was that
was probably harder than anything else
oh I have so many followup questions
we're we're having a a dwindling time
too I'm going to I'm going to try squeez
in three more here because you brought
up Sarah you have an exceptional
Ensemble around you in the film in
addition to her and Bradley can you name
a time when a scene partner gave you
just what you needed to you know either
crush a tough scene or even find
something in Felicia that you might not
have been able to access without them I
mean Sarah was definitely in that scene
in Palm Court she was just so because
you know earlier on in the film Shirley
had been so kind of you know eccentric
and
um kind of you know loud and kind of
imposing and then suddenly in that scene
you know which we would say is probably
25 30 years later there's so much about
Shirley that's like bedded in and
grounded and she's aged and she's and
you can see that they' formed a
relationship and she was so she just
listened so effectively which I think is
a completely underrated skill from an
actor that you just are able to listen
and she was so she was just an open
vessel of listen listening the whole
scene and I found it yeah I was just
incredible to act with listening and
good reaction shots I feel like when
we're talking about the E Cathedral part
you were kind of uh lessening the value
of what you were doing in that scene but
every reaction shot just says so much
and that should always be praised as
well right because you brought up how
good the writing is in this movie I'm
going to reference one particular scene
that I love and kind of ask you a
personal career question using it so
it's the moment when they're having
lunch and someone essentially says to
Leonard you know you should change your
last name the the music that you want to
pursue is is how how do they how do they
refer to it like it's it's not the right
music it's not serious music that's what
it is and then she tells him that's the
kind of work she wants to see she wants
him to share it with him who is the
Felicia in your career the person at
just the right time that told you pursue
what you want even if other people told
you it's silly or you shouldn't do that
well my my agent who's been my agent for
20 years um she she told me I mean just
after an education she said basically
you've got a very very brief and and
privileged window where you will be
asked to do things and in that time you
should only take things that you can't
bear the idea of anybody else doing and
they should just follow that to the
letter and not and she's always she's
never pursued anything other than good
work and been supportive of that so
that's meant theater and independent
film for the most part and and then jobs
like this which I would have yeah I
would have sort of gone through squid
game to get this to get this job um I
hear they're casting season to you can
sign genuinely genuinely make your
painter movie and then you go on squid
game The Challenge I would just want to
be in the reality show cuz I just love
it how would you which game would you
lose on I'm not good at the licking the
the the um biscuit thing I'd love it but
I don't think I'd be good at it right I
respect that I wouldn't lose at any of
the games I would lose is it living in
the dorm I couldn't handle that yeah
know I wouldn't let that all right I
have to uh ask just one last question
this is my favorite question but nobody
likes it but I don't care because I
think it's important oh God in this
industry some people out there know this
I've gotten in the habit of ending on
this a lot because I think it's a
beautiful thought a lot of a lot of
people in this industry give Awards to
each other and that's wonderful no one
says good job to themselves nearly
enough I want you to pinpoint something
you did in Maestro that you think you'll
be able to look back on and say to
yourself damn I'm proud of what I did
there oh
God I'm English this is I'm so used to
this reaction now um you can't get out
of it can't give a cop out
answer
um writer what should I say my best
friend's here he's like
nothing counting count counting oh
counting oh no this is nice um no so
there's a bit there's a bit at the
beginning of the film thank you um where
we're sitting back to back and the day
that we shot that Bradley said um I'm
going to do this big crane thing and
that's going to come in on us and we're
going to be sitting back to back and I
want you to think of a game that we can
play and I was like and it was my first
day of shooting and I was like he's
challenging me the director's
challenging me um anyway I thought of
this game and it was a game that my
brother and I played when we were kids
where we would sit across the table from
one another and hold hands both hands
and look in the eye and we would um try
and see if we had a psychic connection
and we would try and send each other a
number between between one and 20 and so
I'd look in his eyes and go like that
and then he would try and guess and
anyway for years we we thought we had a
psychic connection but that was the game
so yes I put that in the film for my
brother that's that's a great answer and
that's an extremely memorable element of
the film you should be proud of that
congratulations on Maestro and
everything you've accomplished thank you
for sharing some of your experience with
us thank you thank you so much thank you
all for being
[Applause]
here